let's close out with one last musical
story I hope will bring you some Joy
this is what I'm liking
[Applause]
the transformative music can be for the
past 12 years girls in Nebraska have
learned that firsthand taking part in a
program that uses pop music as a tool to
instill self-assurance it's called Omaha
girls rock and we have the executive
director on the line right now watching
on KETV everybody please say hello to
Hallie
hi
what's up so tell us more about the
program oh my God Kelly I would love to
so our mission at Omaha girls rock is to
empower youth to use their voice and we
do that through music so our
organization has year-round programming
we do instrument instruction we do after
school programming but the biggest
programming that we have and the most
popular are our summer camps where in
five days our youth with or without
musical experience are learning and
instrument forming a band writing an
original song and on the fifth day
performing when they headline a showcase
at a local music venue so it is a
phenomenal organization and it's my
honor to be able to be here with you oh
my gosh it sounds incredible I would
love to be a part of this when I was a
kid so you you use popular music to
create conversations with the kiddos so
how do you do that I think it's the
easiest way for our teaching artists to
begin relationships or start forming
those relationships with the youth that
we Mentor so our youth come to us with a
variety of genres that they're
interested in and that is where we begin
our learning that is where we you know
instill the skills needed to learn the
guitar for example but we also are using
a variety of those genres and artists
who are
um you know local national International
to talk about how to take up space and
how to live in the intersections of your
identities because there is not just one
way to be successful we use lizzo for
example and we talk about you know
beginning with the flute is this a
hip-hop instrument and our youth you
know understand that those preconceived
notions about what a pop star is
supposed to be what musicians Rock
um that is up to each of us to decide so
we are all about that self-empowerment
of learning the instrument and also
learning to be powerful exactly as you
are regardless of body size regardless
of race regardless of gender identity
releasing ourselves from those standards
and truly just standing on those stages
in Our Truth man it's incredible it's
like you're helping these kids find
their power and their purpose like all
at once it's really really cool thank
you so much for joining us and also I'm
liking your post right now all right
well that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of friction to
go to erasable pen of the Kelly Clarkson
show want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you so they're
going to write a check to Omaha girls
rock for a thousand dollars just to help
out
thank you
thank you Niall Horan Shania Twain Ava
Max and Grace Gustin y'all have a great
day and if it's not try and change it
[Music]
[Applause]